Maddi with only three wins I don't feel
safe we have no defense
don't worry Julio after the incident I
created a state-of-the-art panic room
Wow I could freak out about not scoring
here are you always stressing that your
30-point games aren't enough you need a
panic room today I think I miss my Super
Bowl window see season going poorly
panic with us we blew a 70 point late
well that's perfect I'll take it I saw
the last bit I'm often father I don't
need one my brain is sort of like my own
panic room
our rooms come equipped with a place to
tweet frustrations a schedule to stress
about we play the Rams and the beds and
podiums for you to insist you're not
panicking at I actually feel really good
about where we're at thank you whatever
I just want to give up luckily for you
we have accepted defeat rooms
I'm not crying your crime each comes
with a Larry Fitzgerald to make it all
better
so Kay if your team is garbage as long
as everyone loves you God he's so classy
so by today because the season isn't
even halfway over
[Music]
subscribe his channel watch my puzzles
I gotta go